right now though we are going to metro
headquarters the undersheriff speaking
right now
the lvmpd we've been having this
conversation for nearly a decade
when we began reforms here on our agency
substantive changes are not just
procedural they're cultural
we have worked hard to ensure that there
is no environment
on this police department for an officer
like derek shaubin
many changes have happened over time
with the guidance and input
of community members and representatives
from our metro multicultural
advisory council these members have
really helped us
learn and implement change and have
championed some of our most important
policy changes
in addition we willingly work with these
faith-based partners
community groups and even some of our
critics
i want to say that i am so happy that we
have some of our community partners here
with us
today standing over here to my right
mujahideen ramadan has been working with
metro
since i was a very young officer brought
up on this agency and you can tell
that's a long time ago with the gray
hair
but i remember sitting there as like a
brand new cop
and he was teaching us about diversity
and biases and how we can overcome those
by working together
next to mr ramadan we have other members
of our community that
that came to us today and said we would
like to be part of this
we would like to be part of what's going
on with your organization
so i want to thank reverend jackson
pastor gaston reverend wright
and pastor cherry and maria barnes for
taking time out of their day
to come here and be with us so thank you
very much
with our partners we've been able to
start working on recruiting a more
diverse police
officer so our agency will better
reflect the community
that we serve we've been making changes
prior to mr floyd's death metro made
several changes in our use of poli
force policy and training policies
to name a few mandating a recovery
position
making that mandatory so that when we
have a suspect in custody we ensure that
they are breathing and their breathing
is not restricted when they're in
custody
mandating a duty to intervene and a duty
to report
when an officer sees another officer or
supervisor sees an officer
doing something improper providing more
direction
in what de-escalation really means and
training our folks
on how to de-escalate making that part
of the fabric of everything we do
every call we go on we talk about the
escalation
we've prohibited choke holds and neck
restraints
we've made changes and we've learned
over time that we have a responsibility
to listen to our community
to you to learn from our community and
to change
the strength of our police department
comes from this community
it comes from you the public among our
many duties to the public
we're here to protect the first
amendment right
to assemble protest some of you may
choose to exercise that right today
and we stand here with you the community
to ensure
hand in hand that they remain peaceful
and the message is heard
this last year has really illustrated a
number
of issues that really impact our
community
and the death of mr floyd was a tragic
event
that should not have happened
having said that today a jury has spoken
and held a police officer accountable
for their conduct
our hope at the lvmpd as we continue to
work collaboratively
and we continue to earn the public's
trust
so i want to thank you all for being
here i want to thank the members of the
community
i want to thank my officers that are
here as well as
members of the media and the public i am
uh willing to take some questions if you
have any questions with me today
a couple questions talk you notice from
channel 13. i'm
curious going forward will you guys be
using this case the derek show the case
in your training now moving forward well
i will tell you this that's not within
our training
and i think there's not a person on this
planet
that looks at that and thinks that
that's okay so that's never been part of
our training or will it be part of our
training but yes
obviously the illustration of what
not following policy results
in i think sends a powerful message
yes sir police officer nasa civilian
community member what was your feeling
when you saw that video and what was you
feeling today when the jury came back
guilty well i will tell you
the day that i first saw that video i
had another employee who's now a deputy
chief come into my office and said you
have to see this video it's the most
disturbing thing i've ever seen
and he says i think a city is going to
burn and
i looked at it i thought i was just
shocked so it was just utter shock and
disappointment
and then today i would say that the uh
feeling is relief
yes many peoples they are calling this
the first real victory when it comes to
seeing an officer
uh held accountable in this country for
the death of an african-american
um also during this trial we've heard a
lot of talk about the blue wall of
silence
what is metro police's reaction to the
conversation that's happened about the
blue wall of silence
and what is being done to make sure that
officers
one thing to you know mandate is to make
sure the officers are actually reporting
when something happens correct so a
couple things to that
number one we don't tolerate it um we
mandate that it does not occur
and we put it in policy but like i said
you have to change a culture so the only
way to change that culture is to enforce
the policy and hold those accountable
that don't follow it
right we train our folks we tell them
what the standard is
we provide them direction on what to do
and how to really attain that standard
and now we have a policy that really
nails it down
and then we follow through and hold them
accountable and we have tracking
mechanisms obviously when we see people
that have complaints we'll hold them
accountable
so i'll take one more question with the
channel
uh talk about these relationships with
the community uh community leaders faith
leaders
you know from this point moving forward
how will you continue to have
conversations with them but maybe
build on that further now that this you
know ground swell has happened over the
past year what's
you know what's the big change the big
movement so i think the important thing
is to continue to have the conversation
this provides us a genesis to continue
having conversations about policing in
america and policing in our community
and i think this draws more attention to
the importance of our community
relationships
whether it's our mac uh council or the
i mean we're involved in thousands of
community partnerships right
every day we have that opportunity to
make a connection with a member of the
public and i think this serves as a
reminder that we're there to serve the
public
and that we work cooperatively with them
and that we continue to make those
changes in law enforcement
the public expects so thank you very
much and then we'll be available for
some questions afterwards i know the
folks from the community will be here as
well so thank you for your time today
right and that wraps up our coverage
from